What’s up guys, my name is Colin McNeil
for theScore esports.
A game Dota 2 can and often does revolve around
Roshan.
The items he drops can be the key
between victory and defeat.
So it’s no surprise that a lot of the game's most memorable plays
have been in and around the Rosh pit.
From Aegis steals, to denies, to ganks, to baits,
here are the Top 10 Roshan Plays.
Holding the record for the youngest player
to ever win TI, our number 10 play sees Sumail
put on a show inside the Roshan pit.
In Game 3 of the 2017 Kiev Major, Sumail blinks
into the pit and lands an insane, five-man coil
to completely wipe SG and secure the Aegis.
(Casting)
Known for their early Roshan kills, No Tidehunter
comes in at number 9
with a creative play that lured EG into a deathtrap.
During Dreamhack Winter 2012’s grand final,
AdmiralBulldog sacrifices his life to Roshan,
replicating a failed kill, as he baits EG
towards him for a gank to remember.
(Casting)
Dota 2 is a game that isn’t short on creative
plays, and number 8 on our list shows us just that.
In the G-1 Champions League Season 5 Finals,
Alliance stuns everyone with an incredible
Level 1 Roshan steal, so early, that even
the casters were caught off guard.
(Casting)
Our
number 7 play sees, S4 come out of nowhere
to absolutely blind-side Ad Finem, as he jumps
in the pit to steal the Aegis
and turn the tide in OG’s favor.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 6 is MMY’s cheeky play
to steal Roshan and deny the Aegis
with only familiars against CDEC.Young during Game 1
of The Summit 4 China Lower-Bracket Qualifiers.
(Casting)
Number 5 goes to EG’s Cr1t, who pulls off
an incredible play as he jumps into the pit
against compLexity to steal both Roshan and
the Aegis,
topping it off with a kill onto Limmp.
(Casting)
Number 4 on our list is a god like play that sees Liquid’s GH deny Secret’s Puppey
and KheZu of the Rosh steal during an elimination game at TI7.
(Casting)
The third spot on our list goes to the legendary Six Million Dollar Echo Slam at TI5
With CDEC grouped up tight in the pit, PPD and Universe went in with am Ancient Apparition-Earthshaker wombo combo
that utterly shredded CDEC’s health bars, effectively winning the game then and there.
(Casting)
There are many kinds of plays in Dota 2, but
the difference between average and amazing lies right here, at number 2.
During Game 3 of DreamLeague Season 8 versus
Mineski, Abed single-handedly carries Fnatic
and pulls off a game-saving play
that sees him secure a three-man kill and steal everything from Mineski.
(Casting)
Steamrolling past the competition at number
1 on our list
is none other than ah fu’s disgusting Aegis steal.
During the semi-final match of TI7 between
Virtus Pro and LGD Forever Young,
ah fu leaps into the Rosh Pit as he snatches away the Aegis
in a play that could only be described as larceny.
(Casting)
Well guys that’s our list.
But If you thought we missed out on a sick Roshan play
that should have been in this Top 10, keep it to yourself okay?